We live in an age of mass surveillance.
And big data, mixed with the ever increasing
power of artificial intelligence, means all
of our actions are being recorded and stored
like never before.This information is being
mined to identify social media trends for
targeted advertising, but it’s also being
used to predict riots, election outcomes,
disease epidemics and that’s not to mention
the vast networks of surveillance cameras
that could be used to track crowds and individuals
in real time.
This is EMBERS.
A computer forecasting system that sifts through
the data that you post on social media everyday.
It mines platforms you’d expect like Twitter
and Facebook... and it tracks things that
you might not expect - like restaurant apps,
traffic maps, currency rates and even food
prices.
Data from tweets and social media is useful
for predicting both disease outbreaks, and
events like civil unrest, domestic political
crisis, elections, and so on.
You can use these non traditional data sources,
like restaurant reservation information, hospital
imagery and so on to predict the flu.
EMBERS mines big data for trends rather than
information on individuals.
For example, if EMBERS detects a mass cancellation
of restaurant reservations and then hospital
parking lots fill up, the system can predict
that there is probably an outbreak of food
poisoning or flu.
And it’s incredibly accurate.
EMBERS correctly predicted Hantavirus outbreaks
in Argentina and Chile in 2013 and political
uprisings in Brazil and Venezuela in 2013
and 2014.
In fact, EMBERS is correct in it’s predictions
about 90% of the time.
But EMBERS does have its limits.
While it can mine public data to forecast
major social events before they happen, it’s
can’t predict spontaneous events - like
crowd stampedes or terrorists.
An increasing concern in an overcrowded and
unstable world.
Which is what Dr Mubarak Shah and his team
are trying to do.
They are using video surveillance, AI, and
complicated mathematical algorithms to track
and predict the movements of dense crowds
and the individuals in those crowds.
Crowd analysis is a very interesting area
and very challenging, when you have thousands
of people, it becomes very, very complicated.
This is where A.I. comes in.
It can help spot abnormal patterns in a crowd
like bottlenecks.
Take the Hajj pilgrimage in Saudi Arabia for
example.
In 2015, hundreds were crushed to death in
a stampede.
In the future computers may be able to detect
bottlenecks in real time and pilgrims can
be diverted to uncrowded areas, thus avoiding
stampedes and ultimately, saving lives.
Another application Shah’s team is working
on is to track individuals in crowds in real
time.
We want to be able to track that person where
the person enters, where he's going and where
exact sitting and so on.
This kind of surveillance is done manually,
but computers are beginning to be able to
detect individuals acting suspiciously as
they move through a crowd.
We want to be able to analyze the video in
each camera.
We detect people, we track, and we identify
and so on.
Using video surveillance and the networks
of cameras available in major cities, Shah’s
team is working on using AI to track individuals
from place to place.
This Boston bomber was seen in many different
locations, so you detect a person in one camera,
then it disappears because it's not visible.
And after sometime it reappears in another
camera maybe at a distance.
Re-identification in the crowd is much, much
harder because there are lots of people.
Camera networks data mined for suspicious
behaviour could stop future bombings.
But it isn’t easy and they aren’t there
yet.
There is so much data that needs to be annotated
so that machines can understand human behavior.
It can help law enforcement it can make them
more efficient and it can help solve crime.
But there is a downside to this.
How much privacy are we willing to give up
to be safe?
The implications of these technologies are
vast.
Perhaps It depends on how much you trust the
people who are mining your data.
For more science documentaries check out this
one right here.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.